[Musique]
aujourd'hui pas lui alexandre alors
aujourd'hui je te proposait la plaine
des cafres à la rencontre de monsieur
les poules qui a pu bénéficier de
travaux chez lui grâce au dispositif
département l'amélioration de l'habitat
ah ça tombe bien j'ai des travaux encore
chez moi tu vois que bons offices et moi
aussi c'est qu'on ait rage ou déjà très
bien case si vous aussi souhaitez être
accompagnés pour bénéficier de l'aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat à le rester
avec moi
[Musique]
je vous retrouve à la plaine des cafres
chez monsieur red bull qui a bénéficié
du dispositif
amélioration de l'habitat fait d'être
financier du département de la permis de
réaliser de travaux à son domicile
allons à sa rencontre
[Musique]
doulaye la plaine des cafres cheyrou
semble a pu bénéficier de cette aide à
améliorer son habitat explique hanno
comme on a entendu parler de cette aide
et quelles sont les démarches qu'il a
fait là produits de bouche à oreille a
appelé la personne explique en moi il
fallait les conseil général malabar
attirons puis à mon dossier et à la
suite malgré tout les papiers qu'il
fallait et aux dépôts de dossiers dans
le service le plus proche de chez moi et
quels sont les travaux qu'elle a été
fait les travaux qu'elle a été fêtée
c'est le plafond des toilettes et salles
de bains et l'électricité on avait
beaucoup d'humilité qui remonté dans le
mieux était dangereux la moelle et
puissant sécurité - madame est membre
mais quoi ça c'est justement c'était la
paix à me roux de fer ou n'aurait pas pu
faire
financièrement on n'aurait pas pu faire
parce que on apprend les moyens
les afriques ou tellement chaigneau
mieux si le conseil général doit et
donne mais aussi au nord mais si maroni
depuis plus de 40 ans le département
aide les ménages fragiles à revenus
modestes pour l'amélioration de
logements les personnes concernées sont
majoritairement les personnes âgées et
ou handicapées
jonnhy quelles sont les démarches à
faire pour bénéficier de cette aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat un ménage
doit retirer un dossier d'admiration
méthane dans un point d'accueil concédé
pas moins tant le plus production de
missiles il doit compléter avec des
pièces qui sont indiqués dans le
formulaire notamment les revenus le type
de propriété ou le bail puis il dépose
dans ce coin d'accueil qui peut
bénéficier de ce dispositif
se disent possible dead s'adresse aux
ménages propriétaires locataires du parc
privé à savoir les personnes âgées de 60
ans et ou en situation de handicap les
familles d'accueil les familles en
suroccupation sollicitant une création
de chambres et enfin les familles moins
de cent ans dans une situation de danger
ou de fragilité ayant un rapport d'
enquête combien de ménages ont pu
bénéficier de cette aide le nombre de
logements ont doublé sur la période 2021
de 25 dans le cadre du plan d'action
un logement ainsi 4000 ménages pourront
bénéficier parents ont de cette aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat merci merci
mahony
grâce à l'aide de l'amélioration de
l'habitat du département les ménages
peuvent prétendre à des travaux liés à
la sécurité à la santé et l'hygiène à
l'accessibilité adaptation des
sanitaires est la création d'une chambre
en cas de suroccupation un soutien que
la permet de vivre dans de meilleures
conditions et plus sereinement
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations ce l'aide à
l'amélioration de l'habitat n'hésitez
pas vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affiche sur votre écran le département
des générations fait fini souhaitez-vous
voir cet épisode ainsi que les dépôts
des précédentes pandémies sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je me
retrouve très vite fort nouvel épisode à
bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous amène chez
madame le bon cette agricultrice a
bénéficié du soutien du département pour
la certification bio un joli coup de
pouce pour l'aider à financer ce fameux
label
[Musique]